let's talk about some sane people you
know about this elon musk guy the tesla
guy the spacex guy the neurolink guy
that guy well just yesterday he voted
for the first time in his life for a
republican
we've got a tweet from the texan uh
republican myra flores has won the
special election for texas's 34th
congressional district flipping a seat
that has been
under nearly unbroken democratic control
for four
decades now a little more on the the
district itself it's an 84
hispanic district
and uh it's a border district so do you
think that people who live on the border
of texas and mexico who are watching
immigrants not immigrants illegal
immigrants
not immigrants okay immigrants implies a
level of legality who are watching
asylum seekers or criminals or drug
cartel people etc etc
come into the country do you think
they've had enough and they know that
it's the biden administration that's
just allowing these people in and
interestingly the media is going to
struggle with this because how can the
media call these people racists because
they're hispanic they're often mexican
themselves many of them came here
legally but why are they against illegal
mexicans coming so this is fascinating
uh by the way the woman there flores she
will be the first mexican-born woman
elected into congress and she's a yeah
republican hot diggity dog so how is
this connected to elon well he voted for
her look at this elon musk on the
twitter machine i voted for myra flores
first time i ever voted republican
massive red wave in 2022. now there was
an interesting response to his tweet
there let's jump into that uh tesla
owner silicon valley just a random
twitter account said to him i assume
republican for president two he wrote
tbd but then it goes on a little bit
more
what are you leaning towards and there
it is desantis
desantis so do you see what's going on
here elon musk is not a traditional
conservative a contr a traditional
republican right whatever the scary idea
of that thing is that you probably are
that i probably am at this point right
but what he is doing is running away
from the lunacy and that's what
everyone's doing and this is going to
leave joe biden and his media cohorts
very alone and once it has imploded
enough the woksters will and i mean the
squad and the people who have used him
the the progressives that have used him
to just infiltrate the system they will
drop him too and everyone will be saying
oh we always knew something was wrong
with him and he was a horrible choice
and the scary part of this is that the
progressives will be saying ah see this
was our last ditch effort to tell you
that capitalism and democracy or the
united states even works we have to go
further to our socialist literacy so the
democrat party is j is gone but the
point is that the conservative camp is
becoming a sane political refuge for
generally a political people all elon
musk is saying is
i want to live my life i want to
innovate i want to build businesses all
of those things
so it's super super interesting here he
also had another tweet
about what happened what would happen
and what has happened uh related to
building a company in say california
versus building a company in say texas
look at this
in texas oh so this is this is tesla
owner silicon valley quoting elon musk
uh in texas it took us 18 months to
build a gigafactory in california we'd
still be working on the permits and
probably getting sued so what he's
referring to there obviously is that he
moved tesla a year and a half ago
roughly out of california because of
high taxes because of lockdowns all of
the crazy insanity he moved it to texas
and then hot diggity dog what happened
he can start building faster and more
efficiently there are less taxes on him
as a corporation less taxes on his
employees that he brought there now the
hope is that his employees will realize
that they had to flee a blue state and
come to a red state uh you know i feel
that i should in light of this i should
put a little more money in the in the
jar to get a democrat to leave florida
you know some people are pissed at me by
the way that i changed it and now it's
to get a democrat to leave florida
instead of rescuing a california so
we'll it's still 50 50. i'm not exactly
sure at the end of the year we will
decide and we'll figure it out i know a
lot of people i've met a lot of people
on the on the road who are like dave i
want that cash i got to get out of cali
uh but this is really interesting stuff
and the point is that this stuff is
somewhat apolitical this is about people
taking responsibility for their lives
this is about people trying to figure
out where they want to live that's more
in line with their values where they're
not going to be hit with
taxes and all of those things